(ringing of phone)
- Hey, what's up, Will?
- Hey, Alaska, what's up?
- Not much, how about you, dude?
- Do you maybe want to eat some bagels?
(clang of percussion)
- Did you say bagels?
(upbeat electronic music)
- Bagels.
- We're talkin' about bagels.
- Fresh bagels.
- Bagel angel. (laughs)
- Poppy seed bagel.
- Sesame seed bagel.
- Time to toast!
It's time to toast!
- It's time to toast!
- Time to cut the bagel.
(sawing of knife)
(squirt)
- Well, what's the matter, buddy?
- Aah!
(squrting of blood)
- Will, no, Will!
(bubbling, squirting of blood)
(high pitched metallic squeals)
(shrieking)
- Why did we do this?
(clang of percussion)
- [Voiceover] In 2008, 1,979 people
suffered a BRI.
These victims were cut so badly
that they ended up in an emergency room.
- Bagels, not even once.
- This advertisement was funded by the
American Council for More Croissants.
(electronic whir)
(rusty squeak)